NATO says Russia's long-awaited
offensive in eastern Ukraine has begun
heavy fighting is taking place as
Ukrainian forces try to repel the
attackers Charlie dagada went to the
front lines where casualties are rising
fast on both sides
Ukrainian military hardware on the Move
Along the front line north of bakmut
they have to keep moving the moment they
stop the Russians take aim
explosions rang out both incoming and
outgoing jittery soldiers told us not to
hang around Long spread out and get
ready to hit the ground
the sound of explosions has been
non-stop both outgoing and incoming this
is the last ukrainian-held Village
before the Russian front line about
three miles in that direction commanders
tell us the front line has only moved a
few hundred yards in the past couple of
months in some cases the soldiers are
holding off the Russians using no more
than automatic weapons is it always like
this always there's constant incoming
call sign Thunder tells us it all
depends on whether they can see what
they're shooting at we try not to get
spotted you said before that the
fighting is very close how close
it can get as close as five meters
roughly five yards we're literally
tossing grenades at each other close
enough to throw grenades close enough he
said to find Russian soldiers fighting
From The Trenches the ukrainians dug and
the other way around
like bakmud south of here the fighting
has crawled to a bloody grind for months
the Russians advancing forward in
distances measured in feet and costs in
the number of dead on both sides they're
trying to hold this ground in the face
of an expected Russian offensive ahead
of the one-year anniversary of the
invasion next week even if there's not
much left to hold
despite suffering casualties they
continue to hold that line but there are
indications this morning that Bach moot
might be ready to fall to the Russians
civilians Aid agencies and journalists
have been barred from getting anywhere
near the city
Gail
boy Charlie the one year anniversary
next week and it's still going on no end
in sight thank you very much